all right we are live on rumble youtube
and blaze tv i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report and it is friday which
means it's time for another friday round
table extravaganza i'm in a seriously
good mood today because of the story
that is happening right now and joining
me is the editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial libby emmons co-host of
viva barnes law locals.com and new
floridian with the craziest hair in the
entire state viva fry and the host of
the news and why it matters on blaze tv
sarah gonzalez welcome to the show guys
thanks for having us good to be here we
had a couple minutes before the live
stream and i am so into this martha's
vineyard story it's beyond imagination i
feel like i've waited my entire life for
this i feel like this is the mass red
pill moment i feel like liberals are
being mugged by reality it's so
spectacular so that's sort of where
we're gonna spend most of the half hour
uh i should just update people real
quick if you don't know what's going on
basically these uh illegal immigrants as
you know the border is basically totally
porous we're gonna have two million
border crossings this year it's
completely insane the democrats are
pretending that they're doing something
but they're simply not
so 50 of these illegals end up in
florida and governor ron desantis does
exactly what he promised to do which is
send them to sanctuary cities in this
case he chose uh martha's vineyard and
of course the democrats here in florida
are all attacking him he's heartless
he's evil how could he do this this is
horrible hitler blah blah blah and it
turns out that virtually every democrat
in the senate here in florida actually
voted for the budget that allocated the
money that i mean you just can't make
any of this up it's just so perfect oh
and one other thing before we get
started it turns out in the last 10
minutes or so a bunch of buses have
already gotten
to martha's vineyard to bus
these 50 people off the island so man
liberals can get it done when they
really want to all right we're going to
get to the to the team here and all that
let me just talk to you about real
estate agents i trust real quick uh you
guys know that buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent usually our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they work with only full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just head on over to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some basic info their team will contact
you to make an introduction to their
preferred agent in your town you likely
move to florida and live happily ever
after
okay so here we go uh let's do a little
media coverage of what is going on in
martha's vineyard vineyard first here is
whoopi goldberg of the view
yesterday undocumented immigrants were
put on planes and flown from texas to
martha's vineyard in massachusetts
florida governor
ron desantis said he used his state's
funds to do that that means taxpayers
paid for it and his spokespersons added
that places like massachusetts and new
york should take care of them since
they're the ones inviting them here by
calling themselves sanctuary cities i
get that i i understand what they're
trying to do i get their char they're
trying to make a point but it's these
are people you're playing with these are
real live people with children and older
people and you know we can work it out
but if you're going to be a bonehead
yeah who wants to play with you
whoopi goldberg talking about boneheads
you gotta love it okay so just really to
be clear guys it's a democrat
administration so if the fault starts
anywhere it's with biden that's number
one as i said desantis had it in the
budget the florida dems voted for it the
dems in these cities created sanctuary
cities so everything that is supposed to
be happening is happening right now
libby
are they is desantis a bonehead
i think this is actually really a very
smart political move uh people are
complaining that desantis has
politicized illegal migrants here and i
think that clearly the bible
administration had already done that by
saying that the border was closed when
it was
obviously very very open um and this
actually brought
the stories of this border crisis to
mainstream media where it has been
absent for some time people are ignoring
the problems that we're facing at the
border and desantis was able to uh bring
them to the fore and i think that that's
uh that's certainly worth this and it's
not a bonehead move at all americans
need to know what's going on and the
democratic leaders in this country need
to do something about it they're clearly
able to do something about it when 50
immigrants who aren't there to clean the
homes of the wealthy show up on martha's
vineyard so why can't they do something
about it in the border towns and border
states where their help is really needed
right exactly as you drive the point
home i mean they already bust them off
the island in basically 24 hours obama
did not open up his 30-acre estate and
give them a quarter of an acre or
anything like that sarah you're in texas
the texas border towns have been overrun
for years
um are you upset that the media has
ignored that while suddenly freaking out
about martha's vineyard
yeah it is really frustrating to hear
not just the media but also you know
chicago mayor lori lightfoot and new
york city mayor eric adams all of these
these leaders talk about the influx of
migrants that they have and they just
don't have the resources to handle and
they're talking about 9 000 migrants 6
000 migrants they're talking about
minute numbers compared to the migrants
the illegal immigrants who are pouring
through the borders here in texas you
think eagle pass texas has the resources
to to you know take care of all these
migrants you think mcallen texas has the
resources to take care of all of these
migrants clearly these border towns are
not equipped to deal with all of this
influx and nobody seemed to care until
it came and fell in the democrats lap um
i mean i i will say
i'm glad i hope as you pointed out that
maybe this is a red pill moment for you
but texas has been dealing with this for
a long time and i would also say to
whoopi goldberg you know i would agree
with her that these people are being
used as political pawns i would say that
they started being used as political
pawns by the left for years and years
and years the left have been the ones to
weaponize minorities
not just the hispanics not just the
people pouring in across the southern
border but also blacks and all of the
other minorities that they have been
using as political pawns for so long and
there is nothing that makes that more
obvious than the fact that when you
actually
make them
that hold them to the same standard that
they have been imposing on the rest of
us and say you know what you're the one
who wants them here you're the one who's
opened up your city as a sanctuary city
here you go you go ahead and put your
money where your mouth is all of a
sudden they don't want to do that it's
because they have been the ones who have
been for so long had no consequences for
their policies now that they do it
becomes very clear it's unsustainable
yeah that's why i love the phrase
liberals mugged by reality it's as
simple as that check out this tweet from
elizabeth warren on this i think it gets
to the heart of a lot of what you're
talking about there she said uh
exploiting vulnerable people for
political stunts is repulsive and cruel
massachusetts is fully capable of
handling asylum seekers and i'll keep
working with local state and federal
partners to ensure we have the necessary
resources to take care
for people with dignity of course i then
retweeted it because we've all got to be
snarky on there i wrote breaking native
american welcomes illegals to her
reservation uh viva i mean it sounds
like elizabeth warren is actually cool
with this she doesn't like ron desantis
but they've got the resources she's
going to take money from other people
and give it to other people while
pretending to be a good guy she should
be very excited about this
the hypocrisy that this has revealed is
stunning in real time elizabeth warren
says people are not political tools to
be used for political purposes and then
in the second half of that tweet she
proceeds to use people as political
tools for political purposes the idea
that it's not in my backyard but we love
it and then when it gets into their
backyard they say without any shame
without even any second thought well
we're not a border town so we're not
supposed to deal with this this is
supposed to be for those border towns
not dc not martha's vineyard and then
when it gets into their backyard they're
like maybe this isn't all hunky-dory
maybe this isn't exactly what we should
expect everyone else to do and they
start walking back policy in real time
there was an article in uh nbc boston
asking the question is boss is
massachusetts really a sanctuary state
it's complicated it's not complicated it
was very nice they all you know virtue
signaled when the highest court said you
can't arrest someone or ask them about
their their immigration status they love
virtue signaling when they can get the
points but when reality comes to their
front door all of a sudden they want to
backtrack a little bit it's complicated
let's get them off the island let's get
them back to these border towns because
we're not a border town right not that i
need to drive the point home about their
hypocrisy but here's a tweet from gavin
newsom on this uh what governor ron
desantis and governor greg abbott are
doing isn't clever it's cruel i'm
formerly requesting that the doj begin
an immediate investigation in these uh
into these inhumane efforts to use kids
as political pawns as everyone here has
already illustrated if someone's doing
something inhumane it's the people that
let them in when they are by definition
breaking the law at that point sending
people to martha stewart martha stewart
martha's vineyard sounds pretty good
martha stewart probably has a place on
martha's video though i would imagine um
all right here's some video from msnbc
because
chuck todd must have a summer home there
and he's freaking out because the
infrastructure might collapse
and it's all
due to treating people as political
pawns
leaving some migrants who might have
been misled to believe they were going
elsewhere as reported by npr on a
literal island that doesn't have any
infrastructure designed to help them
at all
in a word it's inhumane
in a word chuck todd's a [ __ ] i mean
it's just incredible it's just
incredible it's a literal island that
rich people vacation on uh and it has
some infrastructure hence obama and his
30-acre estate which will probably be
destroyed by climate change sarah can
you talk a little bit since you're in
texas about the infrastructure of some
of the towns that you mentioned before i
mean they must be really robust that
they can welcome in thousands and
thousands of people and it's really just
wonderful it must be so much better than
martha
yeah
absolutely not uh and i think that you
know you're seeing all of these
previously democrat run
small border towns on the border of
texas and mexico all of a sudden flip
and and turn red that is because these
border policies have been devastating to
these communities these are not rich
communities these are actually very uh
in some cases poor communities or you
know maybe middle class farmers just
working to get by but they can't because
their their crops keep getting overrun
by illegals who are i mean quite
literally just walking across and
walking through these farmers yards we
had a couple months ago we had a video
that we played on my show of um i'm not
sure if you saw it of texas national
guard closing a literal gate onto
private property and the border patrol
came and opened it back up i mean these
are people who are saying we cannot
handle this anymore we don't have the
infrastructure for it we've never had
the infrastructure for it please stop
allowing these people to decimate our
town and the federal government is
saying no we're going to let them in and
you know i love that they always bring
up compassion because when you talk
about inhumane and you talk about
compassion
i would love it if everyone could come
here and we could have this great
country where anyone who wanted to come
could come but the bottom line is you
need to make sure that compassion goes
first towards american citizens who are
already living here and i would say it
is not compassionate or humane to force
these people who are living on a border
town to be subjected to all of their you
know their property values are going
down they can't make a living because
these these illegals are destroying all
of their crops the way they make their
living that is what is inhumane and that
is what the federal government is doing
to its own people
libby i always bring up the point that
it's not enough to just point out the
hypocrisy with these people because we
we all get it at this point and and just
doing it over and over again i think
it's sort of important and i do think we
have to mock them to some degree and
address it but do you think there's any
way to get through to someone like chuck
todd i mean the simple truth is if a
border town in texas was being overrun
as sarah is laying out there he simply
will not cover that on meet the press
now if trump had been president and
somehow it would have happened even
though they would have said trump was
racist because of the wall they would be
loving the story right his wall doesn't
even work and blah blah blah now they're
overrunning texas uh texas cities is
there any way to get through to someone
like chuck todd and the audience that
he's talking to
you know i've been thinking about that
as well because we don't see the stories
covered in um mainstream press like that
and i think one thing that these outlets
could do is actually start telling the
stories of some of these migrants as
sarah said it's not compassionate to the
people who live in these border towns to
allow their communities to be completely
overrun they don't have the resources
it's also not compassionate to the
people who are coming north to give them
this hope that the united states can
handle
all of this um you know all of these
extra people who don't have resources
and things here so i think that that's
important to note as well savannah
hernandez has been doing some reporting
for us and she actually told the story
of a young woman who um like not even a
woman a teenager a young teenager who
was sent north by her parents with this
hope that um
she would be able to find a better life
in the united states and one of the
things they gave her for her journey was
a box of condoms and by the time she got
to the border there were only three left
because she had been consistently raped
along that journey i've talked to other
journalists who report from the border
who say that the human traffickers uh
will put bracelets on young girls that
say la mujere on them so that when they
get across the border they know you know
the other
traffickers on the other side of the
border know that these young girls are
destined to be trafficked in the sex
industry
it's not compassionate to the people of
south america to say
abandon your homes abandon your families
abandon your children and come north
when we don't have the infrastructure to
handle everybody and you have the
administration who just seems to think
that if you open your arms and everybody
comes to hug you you won't get
completely trampled and buried under a
giant pile of humanity so that's a big
issue i think there's no compassion for
the
people who are coming they get swept
away in the river their children die
they get raped along the way they are
sold a bill of false promises
it's just insane what we're doing to
them and to those nations by by
pulling their citizens out of their
nations you also see stories of people
claiming refugee and asylum status after
having ditched their home nation
documentation at the border so that they
can do that what are we doing why are we
doing this to these countries and why
are we doing this to the citizens of
these other nations
and on top of all of that uh it will not
surprise you guys that over on cnn they
had documentarian ken burns on with john
berman and of course they're comparing
desantis's move to yes you guessed it
the holocaust we woke up to the news
this morning that governor ron desantis
of florida sent two plane loads of
migrants uh to martha's vineyard off the
coast of massachusetts including kids
and whatnot and i'm not saying this is
not a one for one this is not a parallel
here in any way but it does address some
of the same themes that are part of this
documentary
the abstraction of human life it's
basically saying that you can use a
human life that is as valuable as yours
or mine or limbs and to put it in a
position of becoming a political pawn in
somebody's authoritarian game this is
the coming straight out of the
authoritarian playbook this is what's so
uh disturbing about desantis is to use
human beings to weaponize human beings
for a political purpose it's like when
somebody disagrees with him in florida
like the walt disney company he punishes
them
i mean there's so much stupidity there
just real quick i tweeted out two images
and as you can see that auschwitz and
martha's vineyard are a little bit a
little bit different than each other uh
viva
is this a bit much i mean there's just
no there's there's no bottom to the hole
right there's no can you imagine in the
same sentence where he says it's
inhumane to exploit humans for political
pawns let me pivot into selling my
documentary by the way
it's it's shameless and it's first of
all i don't even care about their
hyperbolic idiotic comparisons period
but they talk about exploiting humans to
sell their books to sell their
documentaries there's no connection
whatsoever and it's almost as bad as
chuck todd comparing 911 to january 6
also speaking of not using people as
political tools but january sixers are
as bad as the terrorists that flew
planes into the world trade center i
mean
they're incorrigible because they're not
honest in what they're doing they are
there to mislead the question is how do
you reach their base
i think it's happening in real time you
can feel the seismic shift in the social
media universe and the more that they
compare this taking migrants and
bringing them anywhere in america i mean
they got to go somewhere so martha's
vineyard it's comparable to the
holocaust but leave them in border towns
leave them in detention facilities on
the border towns that's fine because
martha's vineyard doesn't have to see
them then build some detention centers
in martha's vineyard let people see what
actually happens in reality maybe
they'll start changing national policy
right and again putting them on a plane
to martha's vineyard somehow is inhumane
but then when they get to martha's when
you're putting them on a bus back to the
mainland that's somehow good it's it's
rather extraordinary but it's not just
happening in martha's vineyard it's also
happening in dc here's what's going on
over in texas we've got a tweet from
greg abbott who's the governor there
this morning two texas buses of migrants
arrived at the naval observatory in d.c
vp harris claims our border is secure
and denies the crisis we're sending
migrants back to her backyard or to her
backyard and call on the biden
administration to do its job and secure
the border and then of course aoc jumped
in on this i remember how folks stepped
up to help texans when you left them
cold and hungry during the freeze we
will welcome these families too they
have so much to offer you do seem to be
struggling at your job though maybe you
should consider if this is the right
work for you and uh actually before we
before i get comment from you guys
here's video of two busloads of texans
uh two busloads from texas not of texans
from texas of venezuelans who were
dropped off in front of kamala harris's
house
they're showing up at kamala's house it
sounds like aoc wants them at her house
i saw a video of hillary clinton this
morning saying when people show up at
your door you should help them oddly she
has a huge fence in front of her house
at chappaqua uh surprise surprise sarah
the hypocrisy theme continues
yeah it's so funny to me because you
know tweeting about it is one thing and
claiming that you're going to help these
families because they have so much to
offer is one thing but in practice six
months from now 12 months from now when
they continue to have an influx it will
be very interesting to see if they
notice the rise in crime if they notice
the rise in homelessness if they notice
their cities have become dirtier if they
notice all of these things and decide
that maybe that isn't the right path for
them because
again the left is so used to setting
standards for everyone else that they
are not actually they don't believe that
they will actually have to follow
through with
themselves now that greg abbott is
bussing these people over which by the
way uh aoc tried to claim that he's not
doing his job very well well it is in
fact the federal government who is not
allowing him to do his job so i find
that very interesting but you know in
they can say whatever they want will
they actually back it up and put their
money where their mouth is i mean if
martha's vineyard tells you anything it
certainly is not going to last very long
and i would like to to go back to
something about the liz warren tweet
that you put up earlier i noticed that
again just similar to aoc i noticed that
she she claims massachusetts is ready
and willing to handle all of this but
then she mentions in the next sentence
that she is going to partner with
federal agencies well federal agencies
would indicate that you're going to try
to get resources from other states when
you just said that massachusetts could
handle it so it's interesting the double
speak that these politicians give and uh
in in reality they know that if this
continues and they continue having this
influx just as texas has been faced with
just as arizona has been faced with just
as california has been faced with they
continue to have this influx uh they're
going to end up like another mini
california they're going to end up like
a border town you know in california and
i think that it's going to be very
interesting to see them pivot from cute
little talking points on twitter to hey
guys
we got to get these people out of here
because we cannot it's not sustainable
and that's the thing that i think the
left is
just so bad at is they they can't think
logically logistically speaking again i
said this earlier i would love it if we
could just open our doors to everyone
and everyone could just come in but
logistically speaking that is not
sustainable especially with the welfare
system that we have you cannot have open
borders and a giant welfare country and
so it's just so interesting to see the
left continue to think that it's just
sustainable to continue to allow people
in all because they want a better life
that's just not the way the world works
and one last thing dave she talks about
families she always they always want to
mention kids these families are coming
in they deserve better if most of them
are not families most of them are either
children coming in by themselves
with coyotes as libby mentioned in a
very dangerous journey or they are young
men who are coming in from all sorts of
places not even necessarily from central
or south america so it's just so it's
it's so gross for her to try and act
like these are all just families looking
for a better life when in actuality
that's not the case and that's why this
story is just so great because we're
just seeing their lies knocked down one
at a time it's like watching the
dominoes fall one lie goes into another
goes into another goes into another and
then people start realizing look if
you're on martha's vineyard right now
there's a video going around of a woman
who's just a resident there you know
basically saying we don't have the
infrastructure we can't do anything
about this and it's like maybe she's
about to be red-pilled maybe she's
suddenly gonna realize boy i'm not
better than those people that live in
the border towns in texas in california
and arizona and everything else well
then of course you guys probably saw
that earlier in the week kamala harris
did do an interview where she said that
the border is secure
then of course this whole thing happens
and she got asked if that's actually the
case president harris any comment on the
migrants that were dropped off at the
naval observatory
no no laughing that time yeah viva she's
she's better when she's not talking huh
they can't keep up with their own
rubbish you saw jean-pierre you know
trying to answer a question uh
they can't keep up with their own lives
they can't keep up with the faults that
people are seeing in real time just to
get back to something about gavin newsom
dave
gavin newsom suggesting they investigate
desantis for busting migrants to
martha's vineyard as though that's a
federal crime
be careful what you asked for because i
seem to recall joe biden flying underage
children into the middle of new york in
the dead of night although this might be
gavin's long-term play to get desantis
and potus so that he can be the next
potus but
they don't think two steps ahead in
terms of consequences of policies and
i'm saying the political left here open
borders but we're not migrant towns so
so long as it stays in someone else's
backyard okay oh now it's now it's in
our backyard well we don't think we
should use people for political pool to
tools but let's use them for virtual
signaling points online oh let's go
investigate people for for transporting
migrants maybe think that in about one
step that's going gonna backfire on you
because that's what's been going on for
a long time
uh but
social media is a toxic hell hole but
it's also a very useful place to share
the madness share the insanity and share
the information i know i hate it so much
and i'm trying to use twitter less but
the last day or so on there it's the
memes have been great it's like we're
watching you know who knows where
they're where they're you know siphoning
us and and whether people are actually
seeing what we're sharing and all that
kind of stuff but there's been a lot of
fun stuff out there because it's like
man the truth if you can get the truth
out there clearly and cleanly it is fun
uh usually uh so let's speaking of some
of the hypocrisy dc mayor muriel bowser
she is called dc a sanctuary city so
then of course these people start
showing up there then all her homeless
shelters are overrun then she gets very
upset you guys probably saw the video of
the councilwoman there who was very
excited that they were a sanctuary city
now she's freaking out desantis is
hitler blah blah blah here's muriel
bowser on what's going on in d.c do you
think that the
migrants being dropped off here will
make the biden administration see it
more clearly since it's where they live
too
oh i'm pretty sure they understand
and see the the situation clearly
but all the lawmakers here and the
lawmakers at home in texas in their
homes in texas or arizona they need to
understand that we need a system an
immigration system that's that works
that's fair at the border but also is
dealing with the millions of people who
live here who need a pathway to
citizenship
libby
i'm pretty sure that the governors of
texas and arizona do understand it and
that's why they're sending people to her
sanctuary city
yeah i think you're exactly right and we
saw the same thing happening in new york
with mayor adams
starting to question our rules that say
anyone who seeks shelter gets shelter
and this past weekend the city was
unable to house everyone who was seeking
shelter in that city for the first time
in a very long time uh which is of
course a heartbreak i would imagine to
all new yorkers who
endorse these you know this policy but
yeah now that these blue mayors are
starting to see what's going on it is
interesting to
hear them make the exact same complaints
that the governors of border states have
been making for some time i do wonder
however if what's going to happen is
that these democrat leaders are going to
demand as liz warren did more resources
for the from the federal government to
handle these problems and not to handle
them in a way that actually works to
solve the problems but simply to spend
more money to throw more money at it and
just going back to kamala harris wasn't
she tasked with dealing with the border
wasn't she supposed to go down to the
northern triangle countries uh and try
and get people to stay home and instead
she's out there cackling about nothing
and making word salad and uh doing
nothing worthwhile in the government i
don't even know what she's doing there
well let's end then with the reverse of
word salad with the guy who i suppose
sort of started this thing although
really it's biden who started this thing
ron desantis who again
got the funds passed in the budget to do
just this and is now doing exactly what
he said which is what we always ask
politicians to do
well he's got some non-word salad when
it comes to talking about what's going
on right now beating their chest when
trump was president saying they were so
proud to be sanctuary jurisdictions
saying how bad it was to have a secure
border the minute even a small fraction
of what those border towns deal with
every day is brought to their front door
they all of a sudden go berserk and
they're so upset that this is happening
and it just shows you you know their
virtue signaling is a fraud okay
they
they are supporting policies that are
just frankly indefensible it is not
defensible
for a superpower to not have any control
over the territory of its country over
the borders of its country and he
inherited a situation
where you didn't have this happening and
yes we needed to build the wall there
was more that we needed to do he
reversed the trump policies knowing what
would end up happening and you know one
of the reasons why we want to transport
because we obviously it's expensive if
people are coming here you got it taxes
social services and all these other
things
don't you guys just love hearing truth
like when it's just so obvious it's easy
it's pleasant you can breathe it's nice
you know interestingly he makes a great
point there about the virtue signaling
okay we all get that but the point is
it's very easy for all of these democrat
mayors and governors to say we're
sanctuary cities and states when the
border actually works like it did under
trump now the border doesn't work and
suddenly they're very upset about that
uh viva you're in florida now very
exciting to be here wouldn't you say
i'm witnessing it
in real time you know firsthand uh but
you know hearing desantis talk it's easy
to speak freely when you're speaking the
truth he doesn't have to mince his words
he doesn't have to cover up for past
lies uh you know at one point in time i
remember seeing it from from the north
of talking about building a wall was
racist talking about uh problematic
immigration was racist and they said it
now that they've come through
busing them to sanctuary cities is
racist or according to burns hitlerian
and then they say we need a we need a
border policy that works it's only when
the problem the policy problem hits
their front yard that they start making
sense like whoopi goldberg to some
extent uh you know now we need policy
that works now let's be civil with each
other but until the problem gets to our
front door we are politically rabid and
we are uh you know politically partisan
to the extent that anything you proposed
that would have otherwise been a
rational logical solution we're going to
frame as racism bigotry xenophobia
whatever to demonize you
sarah do you feel like people in texas
are uh who maybe were on the fence about
abbott or you know there's this weird
there are democrats in texas it's weird
like do you think people are getting it
there maybe
uh yeah i absolutely yeah especially
when
yeah especially when the alternative is
of course robert francis o'rourke who is
going to do absolutely nothing to at
least try to correct this problem in
fact he would just
let more people in uh and already you
know in already uh you know towns that
are are already suffering so i do think
that it has uh it has strengthened
people's uh ideas that yeah you know we
can't we can't afford to vote any other
way except governor abbott i wouldn't
say that anyone is particularly
passionate about governor abbott uh as
people perhaps are in florida but he'll
do you know he'll he'll do much better
over over robert francis o'rourke i do
want to go back to kamala as well
it's just so fascinating to see the
stark contrast between kamala harris
answering a simple question you
mentioned she was asked if the border
was secure uh you know several i think
it was last week and her answer was just
you could tell she's literally coming up
with every single word in that moment
she has absolutely no idea where she's
going to go to and then you have ron
desantis who is the exact opposite and
gives a very cohesive uh correct answer
i also heard i can't remember if it was
eric adams or lori lightfoot earlier
this week say we need a national
solution guess what guys we have a
national solution it's called enforcing
the border laws that already exist and
the fact that they can't comprehend that
is just amazing to me there is a
national solution the border states are
already trying to get that done so
perhaps now that this has been dumped in
your backyard maybe you will now agree
that we have to enforce our borders
every other nation does it we are no
different and it is unsustainable to do
anything different
libby i'll give you the last word are we
just all mean and callous and maybe we
should just be nicer and say nice things
because people like hearing nice things
i think we're actually being a lot
kinder to these illegal immigrants than
the democrats are who have been using
them as pawns
this entire time to bolster their own
image and then do absolutely nothing to
help these people out
these people who are coming north they
need secure countries they need secure
borders of their own they need more
infrastructure
there and to get that you need your
people to stay where they are and work
hard for the betterment of their own
nations and their own towns their own
families what we're doing is
tearing families apart parents
desperately want something better for
their kids they believe this garbage
promise of the bible administration it
was shortly after biden came into office
that um my orcas said we're not saying
don't come we're saying don't come now
and
you know for months after that we heard
migrants saying biden told us to come by
and told us to come um it's just a lie
and it does nothing for them for their
families or for their nations what we
really need is a strong north america
and a strong south america um
and we're not going to get that under
these policies at all
well i've thoroughly enjoyed this i'm
going to finish up without you guys have
a great weekend welcome to america once
again viva and uh i'll i'll see you guys
soon
thanks
i gotta tell you guys in case it isn't
clear this story to me is everything
that we've all sort of been looking for
it exposes the abject hypocrisy and
incompetence of this administration
right that oh we're sort of having a
border you know we're doing something
and then we know it's not happening and
then they get angry
only when it shows up at their doorstep
nobody seems to care when this has been
overrunning these cities in texas right
and then what happens in texas i mean
it's even more extraordinary you guys
know about the small texas town that
myra flores
just won a republican who elon musk
voted for he says it's the first time
he's voted for a republican the city's
being overrun by illegal aliens she
happens to be latina she wins as a
republican first time a republican's
taken the seat in a hundred years and
then the new york times writes an
article about her the rise of the far
right latina so this story exposes
everything it exposes the incompetence
of the administration it exposes the
hypocrisy of the media it shows also
that when you actually as an elected
official when you do what you say you
are going to do that the media will
still go after you all desantis is doing
is exactly what he said he was going to
do which is exactly what abbott
said he was going to do and desantis got
12 million dollars in the budget to do
just this the democrats in florida voted
for it and now they are all on twitter
today calling him a racist
liberals
if you are watching this and you are
still liberal after this and i don't i
don't want to get into the whittled down
classical liberal argument or anything
else
if you are voting for democrats
you you need help
you need to see somebody
uh not a therapist you're probably in
therapy already because you know that
there's all these studies that uh
usually elitist and metropolitan
liberals are in more therapy than
anybody and have all these extra
psychological problems
the point is the point is there are
basic truths out there
basic truths include having a border and
protecting that border and and doing
what you're supposed to do as an elected
official and assessing these issues
honestly if you're in the media so
hopefully there are some people who who
are being red pilled right now i
honestly believe there might be a couple
liberals up in martha's vineyard who are
being red pilled right now people who
are like wait a minute wait a minute why
why were we a sanctuary city because the
second people got there the the official
martha's vineyard it's not even a i
don't even know if it's their local
government or whatever it is they put
out a statement about the humanitarian
crisis there 50 people 50 people while
thousands show up in texas humanitarian
crisis so they fed them for a day and
they put them on buses and they got them
the hell out of there and chuck todd's
freaking out about it and whoopi's
freaking out about it and everybody else
it's it's just amazing all right a
couple comments from the locals
community tony says i say we send more
make kamala's front yard great again
look i don't love the idea of sending
things to people's houses i didn't like
the idea when they were protesting at
brett kavanaugh's house like i don't
like that as a general rule because
we'll do it they'll do it we'll do it
they'll do it and everyone will be a
target and all of that stuff uh that
being said they've unleashed this thing
they really have just unleashed this
thing we played the clip of kamal harris
the other day when she was asked about
the border and sarah was right she
couldn't say anything it's very obvious
that she they basically said is the
border secure that's what chuck todd
said and she said something like well a
nation is a place with borders and
borders are a thing that nations have
and
and it's like it obviously ain't true
lady because 50 people just showed up in
martha's vineyard and again the obama
thing is just so perfect they'll pretend
they care obama has 30 acres do you guys
know how big 30 acres is i know a lot of
people with some cash i don't think i
know anyone with 30 acres it's a big
amount of land and he has a massive
mansion on the water now i suppose maybe
he didn't want to put the migrants there
because they could be killed like by
climate change you know what i mean the
water the sea level could rise wipe out
the migrants obama would feel terrible
but of course he does absolutely nothing
couple more comments
math says 2 000 additional people in a
city of 3.6 million barely replacements
for chicago victims of violence right
they could just take all the dead people
that are shot every week by gun violence
that we're not allowed to talk about
because the racial component is
backwards um they could just bring in
new people to keep the population up
it's a good point kathy says shouldn't
they love this they are leaving mean red
states for loving blue states you know
what that's what a perfect bow on this
whole thing it's like right
let's pretend we're all really
compassionate about these people we
really care about these people they're
coming to horrible backwards gay-hating
angry mean racist white supremacist
states like texas and florida
arizona now they're going to the love
fest of illinois in massachusetts and
new york and d.c
lucky they're lucky people
uh guys if you want to play along during
the show you can always join the live
chat at
rubinreport.locals.com part three of my
interview with vivek ramaswamy is up
right now and the full things up at
locals already
i'm in a good mood people
ah i was gonna say we could get
chick-fil-a for lunch but we already
ordered lunch
back up chick-fil-a should we have two
lunches today
two lunches it's a bit much it's a bit
much all right guys have a great weekend
see you on monday